quoi de mieux que de commencer cette
nouvelle saison de vidéos avec un gros
écouter les vacances c'est le moment de
prendre du recul de se poser au bord de
la piscine et se rappeler d'expérience
traumatisme ok donc pendant ce mois
d'août
il ya eu pas mal de nouvelles histoires
assez ouf avec des mécaniques différente
de celle que ya habituellement dans
l'east river y en a une que je voulais
pas clermont traité je voulais en parler
avec vous de celle là c'est celle de la
première histoire à savoir l'histoire de
gustave c'est parti l'histoire s'est
produite il ya 20 ans au moment où
gustave la raconte et ça reste l'un des
événements qui l'a le plus traumatisées
de sa vie on est la veille de noël
gustave et samia viennent de passer une
superbe soirée chez la maman gustave
avec sa tante et toute sa famille
éloignée qui voit pas souvent et c'est
la première fois que samia les
rencontres et vous savez quoi
ça se passe super bien il parle il joue
au poker is off des cadeaux et boive des
coups l'ambiance est géniale pendant
toute la soirée autour des 23 heures
gustave et samia décide de rentrer et
précise d'ailleurs qu'au moment où il
part de la soirée samia a bu pas mal
contrairement à gustave et que donc
c'est gustave qui va conduire et ce
détail a son importance pour rentrer
chez eux ils vont emprunter une route
qui longe l'autoroute mais qui n'est pas
l'autoroute
c'est une petite route qui a entouré de
forêt très dense et bien évidemment elle
n'est pas éclairé donc site du stade est
un ses phares il fait nuit noire
mais vous en faites pas gustave a grandi
dans cette région il a emprunté cette
route énormément de fois donc il connaît
très bien
y'a rien à craindre mais soudainement
quelque chose traverse la route du staff
enfonce la [ __ ] de frein au maximum et
miracle il ne heurte pas ce qui vient de
traverser la route du staff qui lui
vient l'idée tout de suite c'est que
c'était un animal et plus
particulièrement un coyote
étant donné qu'on a énormément dans la
région où ils se trouvent mais il ya un
truc qui trouve bizarre c'est que
généralement les coyotes ne cours pas
comme ça devant les voitures ils savent
qu'elles sont dangereuses et les évite
gustave il a un feeling et il sait pas
pourquoi mais il décide d'aller vérifier
il fait donc demi-tour et aimer les feux
de route pour voir plein pot tout ce qui
se trouve devant lui et descend de la
voiture et se dirige à pied vers cette
zone pour essayer de fouiller trouver
quelque chose
encore une fois il a un feeling bizarre
et vous savez d'expérience avec toutes
ces histoires que l'instinct est très
important dans ces moments du staff
s'enfoncent un peu dans les bois et
après plusieurs dizaines de secondes de
recherche qui mène à rien gustave
irréaliste qu'en fait il est
probablement en train de faire une
énorme erreur
son coeur bat à toute vitesse ses poils
sont hérissés mais devant lui toujours
rire juste des arbres des brand
rien d'anormal aucun mouvement aucun
bruit et c'est là que gustave en temps
le klaxon de sa propre voiture
situé à plusieurs mètres derrière lui et
tout de suite il sait qu'il ya quelque
chose qui va partie du staff cours
jusqu'à sa voiture et rentrer dedans et
il se tourne vers samia lui demande
pourquoi elle vient de klaxonner
samia ne répond pas elle est tétanisée
sur son siège et elle lui montre quelque
chose qui se trouve devant elle ce
quelque chose est à à peu près dix
mètres devant la voiture à savoir très
proche de l'endroit où gustave était
juste avant de revenir en courant dans
celle ci et ce quelque chose c'est pas
un animal c'est un homme un homme nu
recouvert de saleté et de boue qui tient
une hachette tout simplement gustave
comme samia est figé il n'en croit pas
ses yeux
et l'homme qui se trouve à dix mètres de
les regarde et souris avant de
s'enfoncer dans l'obscurité dans les
bois la gustave il fait un truc qu'on
aurait tous fait aimer la première et
ils bombardent pendant le reste du
trajet tout va bien se passer mais
gustave et samia n'avons pas échangé un
seul mot ils sont complètement choqués
ils ont du mal à réaliser ce qui vient
de se passer est une fois rentrés chez
eux une fois qu'ils sont sûrs qu'ils
sont bien à l'abri protégé par des murs
et une serrure et vous en parler et
samia va lui expliquer en fait ce
qu'elle a vu et pourquoi elle a klaxonné
en fait pendant que gustave est en train
de chercher dans la forêt et bien cette
chose qui était en fait un mec à poil
avec une machette est revenu sur la
route par l'autre côté et donc du staff
l'a pas vu puisqu'il était derrière lui
ça vient du coin de l'oeil avait du
mouvement elle a alors regardé et elle a
vu cet homme marcher droit vers elle
avec la machette en l'air comme pour
l'agression du coup elle a klaxonné et
l'homme d'un coup s'est arrêté gustave
est revenu à la voiture et puis du coup
l'homme s'est rendu au milieu de la
route pour leur faire peur et vous
connaissez la suite du stage s amis
appellent la police il est prêt vienne
de ce qu'ils viennent de vivre
la police envoie une patrouille ils
cherchent dans la zone i fouilles et y
trouve rien en revanche la police leur a
donné des explications et ils auront
tout simplement dit que le gars leur a
tendu une embuscade et c'est ça la
mécanique dont je voulais vous parler
c'est l'embuscade dans les gens
malveillants qui tendent des pièges dans
le but de voler ou de faire du mal ou de
kidnapper au bref il y en a pas mal qui
se font passer pour des victimes qui se
font passer pour des gens qui ont besoin
des aides et comme il ya pas mal
d'humains qui sont empathique
contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire
bien souvent les gens s'arrêtent et du
coup ils décident de se mettre en danger
de s'exposer pour aller aider
il ya des tas d'histoires comme ça
terrible et moi c'est ça ma thuôt fait
pas des mêmes devoirs des auto stoppeurs
c'est horrible mais j'ai peur je
m'attends est légal les gars après
vingt-cinq très loin je vous jure n'est
plus pareil soyons honnêtes c'est pareil
voilà pour ma première histoire alors
continuer d'aider les gens à l'entrée
bien mais méfiez vous attention toujours
voilà troll je fais passer des messages
je les maîtrise pas les messages que je
fais passer deuxième l'histoire jake et
livreurs de pizzas et l'histoire qu'il
raconte s'est passé il ya seulement
quelques semaines cette nuit là jack il
a énormément de livraison beaucoup de
gens comment des pizzas dans la région
il fait très très chaud et donc jack
boit énormément d'eau le problème c'est
qu'ils arrêtent pas de livrer des pizzas
il n'a pas le temps de faire de pause et
du coup il à l'envi d'uriné qui monte
qui monte qui monte au bout d'un moment
il n'en peut plus il est en pleine
livraison de pizzas et heureusement là
où il doit livrer la pizza c'est pas
très loin de là où il il arrive alors à
l'adresse et tient devant une maison et
la jac
il sait qu'un truc qui m'a pas l'adresse
à laquelle il se trouve et dans une zone
qu'il connaît assez bien puisqu'il y a
fait énormément de livraison de pizzas
et c'est la première fois qu'il arrive à
une adresse et que la maison devant
laquelle it on est complètement dans le
noir pas une lumière allumée pas un
reflet de télévision est pas un bon fou
rire
quoi qu'il en soit il est 23h jack il
est au volant de sa voiture la pizza et
sur la banquette arrière et il n'a pas
envie de descendre de sa voiture pour
aller toquer une maison plongée dans le
noir sans être certain qu'il ait à la
bonne adresse et que le client est bien
dans la maison
il prend alors son téléphone et décide
d'appeler le numéro fourni par le client
coup de chance ça décroche en face et il
tombe sur une fille essoufflée qui lui
dit oui il lui dit alors et c'est pour
la pizza je suis devant la maison mais
il ya personne et la fille au bout du
téléphone lui explique qu'elle est pas à
la maison
elle lui explique a été plongée dans le
tas fait qu'elle n'a pas vu leur passé
et d'un coup elle a réalisé que le
livreur allait arriver chez elle avant
qu'elle ait lyssois et que c'est pour ça
qu'elle est soufflé ce qu elle en train
de sprinter en ce moment même pendant ce
coup de fil pour arriver chez elle jack
cet homme incroyable malgré son énorme
envie de pisser se dit bon je vais
l'attendre mais après avoir raccroché
jack
il cherche des yeux comme ça un endroit
pour une ride il n'en peut plus il n'a
pas perdu l'esprit son vrai objectif
il analyse les environs et voit que
compte le mur de la maison de la fia qui
doit livrer la pizza il ya un tuteur
buste parfait pour se cacher derrière et
urinait et en plus de ça la maison est
vide puisque la propriétaire est en
train de rentrer en courant chez elle
pour choper sa pizza et puis se dit
aussi bons les animaux ils font pipi
tout en dehors les humains c'est des
animaux ça passe et oui c'est le moment
réalise tous que korn à très fort envie
d'uriner dans des deux en effet les
devient fou et commence alors à uriner
et après plusieurs secondes jacques il
entend quelqu'un dire c'est quoi ce
bordel
il pense alors que le pire est arrivé
que des voisins l'ont vu ils se
retournent en pensant qu'ils s'apprêtent
à vivre le moment le plus humiliant de
toute sa vie et anton
elle voit quelqu'un se lever et partir
en courant quoi jack
il comprend rien à ce qui vient de se
passer qu'est ce que ce gars foot elle
est là lui mlle flash de son téléphone
icheck aux alentours y tchèque derrière
les buissons dans les buissons et il
tombe sur un sac
il ouvre alors le sac et à sa grande
surprise dans le sac se trouve un
couteau un rouleau de ruban adhésif et
une bouteille remplie de pilules jack a
la confirmation que la personne qui se
trouvait là quelques minutes plus tôt
avait bel et bien de très mauvaises
intentions et il fait le sprint de sa
vie en direction de sa voiture et
démarre et il fait comme gustave dans
l'histoire d'avant il se casse réalisant
qu'il est complètement en panique est en
état de choc
il appelle la police ils essaient tant
bien que mal de leur expliquer tout ce
qui vient de se passer mais il est
complètement choqué la police comprend
la moitié de ce qui dit il lui dise donc
de rester en ligne avec eux au téléphone
de ne plus bouger de rester dans sa
voiture les portières verrouillées
et puis d'un coup double appel la
cliente appel jack jack ne pouvant pas
décroché puisqu'il est en ligne avec la
police
il reçoit alors un sms de la cliente qui
lui dit qu'elle est devant sa maison
mais qu'elle le voit pas il décide alors
de foncer vers la maison parce qu'il a
vraiment peur que le gars soit revenu et
fasse du mal à la cliente en arrivant
sur les lieux jack aperçoit la femme et
il lui fait des appels de phare pour
qu'elle vienne jusqu'à sa voiture et lui
dit écoute il y avait un mec cachés dans
des buissons
je suis au téléphone avec la police s'il
te plaît monte dans la voiture comme ça
on verrouille les portes et on est tous
les deux en sécurité elle voit qu'il est
bel et bien en ligne avec le 911
donc la police elle monte alors à
l'arrière de la voiture et jack hill et
[ __ ] soulager quelques minutes plus
tard la police les retrouve et jack et
réalise aussi quelque chose à ce moment
là c'est que quand ça se fait que cette
fille soit tout de suite entré dans ma
voiture alors je suis juste un inconnu
qui livre des pizzas
elle m'a tout de suite fait confiance et
ben en fait c'est parce que quand il lui
a dit qu'il était tombé sur un mec
cachés dans les buissons avec un sac un
couteau
elle a tout de suite compris qu'il
s'agissait à 99% sur de son ex-petite
amie
en fait elle avait déjà vécu des trucs
horribles avec son ex petite amie qui
est complètement psychotique et donc
elle en a tout de suite déduit que
c'était lui surtout qui correspondait
totalement à la description qu'on a fait
jack et truc amusant c'est que quelques
jours plus tard elle a appelé la
pizzeria pour leur demander si elles
pouvaient leur laisser un énorme pour
boire parce que il lui a quand même
probablement sauvé la vie évidemment
jack ce gros beau gosse a refusé
évidemment et jack a maintenant toujours
une bouteille vide dans sa voiture
toujours
bref j'espère que vous aussi un jour
vous aurez envie d'uriner au point de
sauver la vie de quelqu'un tout
simplement
bref il est temps de passer à la
dernière histoire celle de paul
l'histoire que nous raconte paola s'est
passé il ya deux ans en 2018 est à cette
époque là elle vivait en belgique chez
ses parents elle précise que ses parents
et ses frères et soeurs sont très
occupés c'est à dire qu'ils ont beau
vivre sous le même toit tout le monde
est toujours dans son coin occupé à
faire quelque chose et en plus de ça
tout le monde un emploi du temps et un
rythme de vie très différent pourquoi il
dit ça juste pour me faire comprendre
qu'en gros elle sait jamais vraiment
trop qui est à la maison et qui ne l'est
pas un soir d'école paula se réveille
parce qu'il ya un bruit dans sa chambre
elle est un peu surprise elle regarde
son téléphone et il est 3 heures du
matin hier lampadaires qui éclairent
juste devant sa fenêtre donc même si
toutes les lumières sont éteintes
elle voit légèrement ce qu'il ya dans sa
chambre elle a la tête dans le cul mais
elle distingue la silhouette de son
frère aîné elle lui demande alors ce qui
fout dans sa chambre à 3h du mat
mais il lui répond pas il se met alors à
marcher vers ses bijoux et elle répète
sa question mais qu'est ce tu fous et
encore une fois son frère lui réponds
pas là-bas aulas commence un peu à
s'énerver parce qu il est 3h du matin et
qu'elle a cours le lendemain elle n'a
pas envie d'être crever alors elles
haussent le ton et lui dit joe pesto
play fous moi la paix demain j'ai cours
joe paix et en traînant son challenge op
la regarde sans dire un mot et marche
vers son sac à main et commencent à
regarder ce qu'il ya dedans et en sortir
des choses c'est le truc de trop paula
est vraiment souley alors elle décide de
se lever de son lit de s'avancer vers
lui en lui demandant plus en plus fort
ce qu'il est en train de [ __ ]
et puis elle le pousse vers la porte et
avant d'atteindre la porte diop et lui
dit où est l'argent
où est l'argent avec un accent qui n'est
pas celui de joe paix et la parole à
elle rit elle lui dit joe pesci pas
c'était bourré ou cités jusqu'en mai
steuplé sors je dois dormir et enfin ils
atteignent la porte elle le fou sur le
palier et elle ferme la porte avant de
retourner dans son lit et une fois dans
son lit paula elle commence à sentir
bizarre elle est nerveuse elle a un peu
peur et elle commença à 1 re penser à
tout ce qui vient de se passer il ya des
détails qui lui viennent à l'esprit par
exemple le fait qu' il sentait la
cigarette là l'homme
sauf que joe paie son frère
fume pas pour être sûr elle prend son
téléphone et elle envoie un message à jo
pl lui demande où il est joe paix lui
répond et lui explique qui vient de
quitter la salle de sport et qui sera à
la maison dans quelques minutes
mais alors qu'ils étaient dans la
chambre paula comprend ce qui vient de
se passer
elle se met à pleurer elle appelle tout
de suite son frère et lui explique tout
ce qui vient de se passer
joe paix lui dit de rester dans sa
chambre et d'appeler la police et lui
explique qu'il sera là dans quelques
secondes parce qu'ils tapent le sprint
de sa vie deux minutes plus tard paula
entend son frère cris et des insultes et
dire aux gars de sortir sa chambre et
toilettage elle sort de cette dernière
et se retrouve dans le couloir et son
père qui dormait en bas dans le canapé
s'est immédiatement levée sous les cris
de son fils et on se dirigeant vers
l'écrit y voit jo paix en train de
courir après un mec
le mec réussi à s'échapper mais dopé
réussi à lui prendre son sac à dos la
famille en état de choc décide
immédiatement appelé la police qui se
rend très rapidement à la maison la
police demande donc à la famille de leur
dire tout ce qu'ils ont vu de manière à
avoir le plus d'informations possible
pour identifier au plus vite les intrus
paula leur décrit alors les vêtements
que portait le mec qu'elle a vu dans sa
chambre vêtements qu'elle a pu
distinguer grâce à la lumière du
lampadaire qui se trouvait en face de sa
fenêtre je crois c'est le seul moment où
c'est cool d'avoir lampadaire devant
tapenade je crois le mec avait un
pantalon noir et un sweat à capuche vert
mais la policière a l'air étonné et lui
dit attendez vous êtes sûr qu'il était
vert parce que votre frère m'a dit qu'il
était gris clair le sweat et c'est là
qu'ils ont tous compris qu'ils avaient
non pas un intrus mais deux ans les deux
intrus sont partis avec quelques ipad
téléphone et portefeuille mais le plus
gros a été récupérée y compris tous les
bijoux parce qu'il se trouvait dans le
sac à dos que joe paix a réussi à choper
au moment de la fuite de l'intrus paula
est dopé réalise que sur leur ipad et
téléphones
il avait installé l'appli find my easy
crois pas trop mais je dispute un ca se
trouve à pouvoir localiser nos appareils
et donc le ravisseur grâce à cette
application on sait jamais s'il pense
pas à la désactiver et surprise
l'appareil est localisée jo paix et son
père saute dans une voiture pour se
rendre sur les lieux de la localisation
et une fois arrivés sur les lieux ils
rentrent pas dans la maison les
attendent l'arrivée de la police la
police entre alors dans la maison on est
repéré là
et tombe sur un mec un mec qui pleure et
qui est couvert de sa propre piste est
vomi dans cette maison se trouve tout ce
qui a été dérobé quelques jours plus tôt
dans la maison de paula et la police
arrête l'homme il a avoué que c'est lui
qui avait fait ça et il a expliqué qu'il
était drogué et que c'était la première
fois de sa vie qu'il faisait quelque
chose comme ça et qu'ils regrettaient et
doper leur connaît c'était le gars après
qu'il a couru et dont il a réussi à
récupérer le sac et du coup paula elle
est soulagée mais d'un autre côté patron
puisqu'elle se dit le mec qui était dans
ma chambre
on l'a pas retrouvé encore souvenez vous
à chaque fois la police généralement
elles trouvent rien ou alors le gars est
arrêté mais n'a pas de news et bien
figurez vous que le deuxième intrus
celui qui s'était rendu dans la chambre
de paula a été retrouvé deux ans plus
tard en revanche contrairement à l'autre
qui était juste un drogué et qui avait
pas du tout de casiers judiciaires qui
n'avaient jamais été condamnées à quoi
que ce soit lui était apparemment un
habitué et il avait déjà été condamné
plusieurs fois pour entre autres vols
conduite en état d'ébriété et surtout
tentative d'homicide du coup pas vouloir
rassurer mais pas trop non plus quand
même il ya quand même ce truc de hoya
vous les buts et un mec le gac et dans
ma chambre aulas eh bien chers amis
j'espère que je serai d'ailleurs vous a
plu c'était le sabreur de la rentrée il
est 1h50 du matin mon style
j'étais bien dans leurs murs la [ __ ]
j'ai voulu raconter 10 de plus ça
n'arrivera jamais aller on se retrouve
bientôt à d'autres vidéos avec des trucs
plus joyeux on a besoin la joie
portez-vous merveilleusement bien et
éviter d'uriné entre de huy sont sauf si
un gars avec une capuche qui est là mais
éviter cette charge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]